[Musique]
0% 0%
c'est votre chance d'être attaqué par un
requin dans une visite et pourtant quand
j'étais jeune j'avais une phobie
qualités vocales et que je m'étais pieds
dans l'eau et là vous savez quand même
plus tard vous éloigner un peu du bord
et là vous avez l'eau trouble doute
autour de vous et avait pu pied et là
vous ressentez cette phobie cette
émotion vous prend les tripes et qui
vous empêche de faire ce que vous
on a tous tes et phobie des peurs de
blizzard il sans trop jamais savoir d'où
ça nous vient enfin dans mon cas j'en ai
une petite idée
j'ai 39 ans je suis à génération et dans
la mer merci enfin moi ça m'arrivait
jusque dans les lycées vous imaginez la
pente en grandissant j'ai décidé de ne
pas me laisser abattre par mes folies et
de faire un métier
étrange un métier bizarre je suis devenu
pilote de patrouilleur maritime dans
l'aéronavale
on vous dirait du coup j'ai passé
presque vingt ans de ma vie les
patrouilles au dessus des mers quant au
rappeur burqa n'était pas la meilleure
idée qu'on puisse avoir mais je me suis
fait et dans ce métier j'ai souvent été
confronté un décalage entre la vision
que j'avais de certaines situations et
le risque réel que dans la vie on fait
tous face à des risques et face à serris
on ressent tous des émotions et surtout
on a une vision très différentes les uns
les autres d'interpréter ces situations
est d'interpréter ses démons aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous parler d'un risque et
notamment de cette étrange décalage de
perception des risques
mais aussi pour faire comprendre qu'il
est possible en intégrant ces peurs en
changeant sa vision des choses
d'affronter seul alors d'abord où sont
vos regards nous quel est votre
présentation du risque est ce que vous
savez qu'il y a tous les ans en france
loin d'une centaine de morts dus à un
accident m
ce chiffre peut paraître élevé mais en
fait il faut le comparer à d'autres
notamment un don on a malheureusement on
entend beaucoup parler c'est le nombre
de tués sur la route on est aux
alentours en france de 3500 morts par an
sur les routes de france
et alors il ya un autre chiffre dont on
n'entend jamais parler un peu comme si
tout le monde s'en fiche et c'est le
nombre de décès dus à des accidents
domestiques en france
onze mille cinq cents membres trois fois
plus que sur la route on pourrait se
dire ben alors on prend plus de risques
à faire cuire ses parts à la maison pour
prendre l oui mais il y en a car elles
qui font peut-être cuir plus souvent
leurs pattes qui ne prennent amiante
voilà il faut réagir en nombre de cycles
égalé justement à nombre de cycles égal
alors pour les pattes je suis pas très
sûr mais enfin ce qui est sûr c'est que
oprean beaucoup plus de risques dans
notre voiture que dans un aveugle
le transport aérien est un des moyens de
transport les plus sûrs au monde
est ce que vous savez que
statistiquement il faudrait voler
pendant 40 mille ans one stop pour être
sûr d'avoir un accident tous les jours 5
millions de passagers sur terre prennent
l'avion en toute sécurité et portant un
passager sur trois avoue avoir peur aux
montants alors je pourrais rajouter
encore des colonnes supplémentaires
quatre-vingt mille morts par an dus au
tabac et je peux rajouter encore une
colonne la malbouffe
on n'arrive même pas à donner un chiffre
tellement c'est catastrophique mais ça
fait plus de morts en france que le
tabac alors quand vous descendez de
l'avion et que vous pourrez vous allumez
une petite cigarette
quelle est la chose la plus risquée vous
êtes en train de vous faire pour résumer
on peut voir que plus ça fait peur ou
moins sa liste ce décalage
d'interprétation des risques est aussi
valable dans nos choix dit dans ma
carrière j'ai eu l'occasion de faire
plusieurs meetings aériens et d'y
présenter des avions et vous pouvez pas
vous imaginer venant de fois où j'étais
dans le cockpit et gens viennent en me
disant a fait un métier extraordinaire
j'aurai toujours tous les pilotes
j'étais super fier c'est génial et alors
naïvement partie mal parce qu'il s'est
passé et vous pouvez pas vous imaginer
le nombre de fois où j'ai entendu un
mais non mais c'est beaucoup trop
difficile pour moi
il faut être super fort en maths super
fort en physique perforant six ans à
l'être humain a cette faculté d'imaginer
l'échec de son projet avant même d'avoir
commencé
combien de personnes imaginent l'échec
de son projet avant d'avoir essayé
combien personnes imaginent voir des
requins dans la piscine avant d'avoir
mis le pied dans l'eau alors je veux
raconter une petite histoire qui qui
s'est passé le 27 avril 2000 mhz
j'étais tout jeune pilote je venais
d'être lâché pilote de surveillance
maritime en méditerranée jeunes affectés
dans le sud est
j'étais affecté sur l'avion le nord 2 6
2 qui est le plus vieux le moins fiable
de doute
première affectation ya mieux mais je
m'en fichais moi j'étais pilote
extraordinaire et cet avion nous servait
à faire des surveillance maritime en
méditerranée principalement autour de la
corse des baléares vous pourrez peu job
pour moi même sur un avion datant des
années 60 mais ce jour là je suis avec
une équipe extraordinaire
j'ai un commandant de bord extrêmement
gentil un mécanicien de bord à mes côtés
très expérimenté et à l'arrière
plusieurs navigateurs et radariste que
j'apprécie énormément une super idée
ce jour là notre avion a subi au niveau
du moteur gauche à voir le décollage une
toute petite réparation et notre mission
du jour consistait à décoller et une
fois à la verticale de terrain d'ajaccio
c'est en corse on devait couper notre
moteur gauche en vol et le rallumer en
vol pour vérifier qu'ils se rallument
correctement avant de partir faire votre
mission c'est ce qu'on a fait alors est
ce que vous imaginez au moment du
décollage
je suis en train de décoller là je me
dis j'ai le plus au bureau du monde avec
une vue imprenable sur les montagnes
dans ce extraordinaire j'ai 23 ans je
suis le plus jeune pilote de mon unité
et la jav est vertical ajaccio et je
fais ce que je veux faire avec mon
équipe on coupe le moteur gauche là on
essaye de le redémarrer les banques mais
ce qui ce passe évidemment jamais il est
parti on a fait une première tentative
et un deuxième tentative rien troisième
tentative toujours bien une quatrième
tentative
et là le moteur au lieu des marraines a
commencé fumée noire il a commencé à
prendre
au même instant je sens comme une odeur
de brûlé dans le cockpit
et je vois sous mon bras gauche de la
fumée qui sort de mon bateau électrique
quelques secondes après j'entends un
grand clac et je vois tous mes
instruments de bord qui se coupe devant
moi aux basques en panne électrique
totale en bas des tricks total sur cet
avion
on a plus de communication entre nous
avec notre père score à dos sans trop
prendre savoir ce qui se passe je me
tourne vers mon commandant de bord et je
vois qu'il est en train de me griller
des choses que je n'entends moi je
continue à me tourner vers mon
mécanicien de bord et je le vois
marquardt avec des yeux exorbités un
petit extincteur de loi alors est ce que
vous pouvez prendre ma place et veut
dire ce que vous auriez fait dans cette
situation là en fait la situation n'est
pas aussi compliqué campement tout est
une question de point de vue
il faut relativiser ces problèmes ça
c'est un peu comme l'histoire du verre à
moitié plein moitié vide sur un bimoteur
vous avez deux moteurs quand un moteur
ne marche pas il vous reste toujours
l'autre moteur marche très bien
vous avez la fumée dans la cabine
on a des masses d'oxygène est je savais
en moins de trois minutes on se reposer
sur l'aéroport d'ajaccio plus de
communication entre nous tout le monde
savait exactement ce qu'il avait à faire
on était entraînée pendant des années
des années aux gros c'est dur sur
simulateurs de vol pour savoir
exactement comment maj d'avancer ses
pions
alors du coup qu'est ce que j'ai fait
comme vous j'ai petit godet
gepci côté on a un petit côté mais tout
en typo temps on à poser l'avion sur un
moteur et en moins trois minutes ont été
posés sur l'aéroport d'ajaccio avec des
pompiers est ce qu'on doit dire qu'on ne
prend pas de risque en volant si les
lobbies et maîtrisée alors relativise un
risque et comment se fait-il que se pose
la question car l'être humain une
machine aussi bien fait que l'être
humain arrive aussi mal relativise et
l'oms pour ça faut se rappeler une chose
c'est qui on est vraiment alors je suis
pas très fort en dessin mais je vous ai
amené un portrait de vous et moi que
j'assure faire face à un risque nous
sommes encore tous les chasseurs
cueilleurs et dizaines de millions
d'années d'une évolution darwinienne
logique pour passer du singe à l'homme
en quelques milliers d'années au pass à
l'homme moderne en quelques centaines
d'années voire quelques dizaines
d'années en avant la technologie moderne
et on envoie notre chasseur cueilleur
dans un avion ou dans l'espace
le chasseur cueilleur est extrêmement
bien adapté à son environnement il ne
connaît que fuite lui d'inhibition face
à un risque par contre il extrêmement
moins bien d'adapter dans cette
situation-là et - chasseurs cueilleurs
dans cette situation la fuite l'usiné
vision face à man risques et ben fuite
je veux pas l'udc je peux pas et
inhibitions alors j'ai quand même une
excellente nouvelle c'est que dans
quelques dizaines de millions d'années
ça ira beaucoup mieux alors quand nous
réfléchissons nous utilisons deux
grandes parties de notre amour la
première partie territoire limbique
s'occupe que des situations simples et
de toutes nos émotions
la deuxième partie le territoire
préfrontal situé à l'avant du front ne
s'occupe elle que des situations
complexes mais aussi tout ce qu'ils
demandent plus de créativité on utilise
tous ces deux partis en permanence en
switch derrière un autre
sauf que face à un risque il ya une des
deux parties qui est automatiquement une
idée c'est la partie créatrice c'est un
système un superbe système
d'autoprotection khaled peuvent un cas
le chasseur pdm et qu'il est face à un
risque n'avons plus que la partie qui ne
gère les situations simples et les
émotions quand on est face à un lyon ou
un ours qui nous sautent dessus on ne
commence pas à philosopher en fonction
de la couleur de l'occe du biome si on
doit partir à gauche ou à droite
non c'est l'émotion qui prend le relais
en l'occurrence ici la peur et nous fait
partir en courant c'est ce qui nous a
toujours protégées depuis des millions
d'années
c'est pour ça qu'on est là aujourd'hui
sauf que ce problème n'est plus du tout
la route est venue doit adapter face à
un risque qu'elle est ce que vous gérez
tous les jours dans votre travail dans
votre vie sociale
ça permet de comprendre une chose c'est
que face à un risque on va avoir un
choix à faire
si on ne fait rien ça pousse notre
cerveau à rester bloqué dans
l'émotionnel et ça ait des gens qui
n'ont bien compris ce sont les
terroristes avec des attentats dont on a
malheureusement tous entendu parler soit
on ne fait plus rien on reste chez soi
on prend plus jamais l'avion
on ne va plus jamais pour un feu
d'artifice on ne va plus jamais promené
sur la promenade des anglais
soit on décide d'utiliser notre parti
créatrice notre cerveau de changer notre
vision des choses et d'intégrer nos
peurs et surtout on continue à bien
on a tous les recteurs la vie et on a
tous besoin de prendre des risques pour
réaliser ses rêves
on a tous besoin de prendre des risques
pour se réaliser soi même
moi mon rêve c'était de pilotes
et vous votre match ces bois alors
maintenant entreprenez osé faire les
choses que vous avez toujours mis de
côté juste par peur de l'échec
et vous aussi vous aurez la chance un
jour de trouver deux nuits en plongée un
sous marin nucléaire rien qu'avec le
plancton lumineux qui passe tout autour
de lui mais vous aussi vous aurez
peut-être la chance d'accompagner la
patrouille de france faire des shows
aériens dans des endroits qui vous
paraissent complètement irréel et vous
aussi vous aurez peut-être tout
simplement la chance de rendre service à
votre star de série télé préférée
moi personnellement c'est l'agent gibbs
dans ncis quant à ma phobie des requins
j'ai décidé il ya quelques années
d'intégrer mes peurs et de me mettre à
la plonge de et je me suis aperçu qu'ils
avaient beaucoup plus peur de voir que
moi je n'avais peur d'eux je suis désolé
pour la qualité de la photo mais c'est
vous qui avez une carte en main c'est
vous qui est le pilote de votre vie car
c'est vous qui avez les commandes de vos
émotions
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]